because as she's larger when she left
the marriage how can she be working on
herself she's not she's just being
selfish she's going out there and she's
wearing the ring when it's with you know
she's using like she's got these
different hats the lone mother hat that
I'm a single woman working on myself hat
and I'm the married woman oh yeah I've
got a husband but I still want to go out
there and find somebody else because
that's what she's not telling them that
she's working on it but yeah she said on
the podcast that she was out there
looking and I I feel like too I feel
like getting in shape helps with being
jealous I don't know if this is just
just because I feel like part of
jealousy is being insecure that someone
will take your yeah you know and so it's
like it makes you less jealous when
you're like I'm high
man somebody made my man jollof rice and
I thought you know what like if that I'm
gonna learn to make jollof rice myself
like it's not gonna happen yeah you know
and if the best way to get over like
jealousy of somebody else so if you
think somebody else gonna fancy them and
if you've got issues work on it okay
don't need to go nowhere else because
you know what African girl ah you lost
out I learned to cook it you know and
that's what you do you work towards it
you've got a bit of toning up I need to
do and I've had people complain about my
flabby boots but I'm old and I can't
wear a bra because of my back so yeah
flabby boobs but you know what I've got
a man happy with him it might work
but if it doesn't if it doesn't we're
still in a good environment and my child
will I will then be able to have the
conversation say especially if we're not
moving on she doesn't need to know
anything other than this is her
situation but you were moving around you
said you're on dating her yes
when if I move on and introduce someone
I can definitely have a conversation and
say look women need to stop that stop
introducing other men to your child
you're a married woman and the child
that you said knows it's Daddy are you
trying to like bring them up in your
dad's culture where he's got two wives
because otherwise why are you gonna turn
around and introduce your young child to
a man don't forget about what if you
can't work on yourself work on your
child don't work on finding your child
another father figure this is what's
happened me and your dad are not
together that's right it's the caveat
though yeah there's not one woman that I
know he's a single parent I'm again I'm
not saying this is you so just a minute
clear there's not one woman I know it's
a single parent that's going to tell you
that her child isn't doing well every
single mother will tell
do you remember I was doing a podcast
and we was talking about crazy mothers
and I set you here my son would say that
and I think he was shocked and I said
yeah he would say that I'm crazy man
because sometimes I was and he knows
that yeah my mum's crazy and I never
ever said that as a single parent I
could never ever say that my son was 100
happy because he never had 100 life you
know if you have a hundred percent life
then you can say yeah you're 100 happy
but he had a father missing and that was
a major especially for a child
especially for a boy so I weren't gonna
go around and say oh yeah my son's
completely happy no my son was okay with
the how the life he had but there was
always that father missing that would
have completed it so she said and then
she rolls up and she hurt herself but
you know what it is
then you start seeing blah blah blah oh
well you know I raised my kid to be a
good kid when you use a statistic back
then now she's just saying I'd also like
to say that most kids develop develop
between the ages of zero and three and I
have some experience with this um just
because I've seen like my parents
adopted and
um I have a friend that adopted two boys
and one was under the age of three one
was over and one ended up like stealing
money from the church and like doing a
whole bunch of like crimes and like he
doesn't really get along with the family
and the other was like a gifted musician
and all this stuff yeah and it just
showed me that even though like under
five you don't really remember like one
just because they were older they really
couldn't influence as much even though
they grew up in the same house with the
same values under really really great
parents but it's like a lot of the
damage that you do is before the age of
three I had I had to fuss the show like
that and because he was so damaged I
just knew that he was like a little ball
of anger I'd love to know how he is if
you're out there Josh but he was a
little ball of anger and I think his
system out with me you know via internet
some social media and it turned out that
oh both had bad lives he was still
really angry and he was angry at her for
putting up with all the abuse that we're
getting so nobody could he's out there
nobody can because he's always like
nobody can mess with him whereas she you
know she was doing modeling and she was
doing this but she was very Placid and
they both suffered tremendous abuse but
nobody could believe that a child that
young could react like that he used to
swear like a trooper you know he used to
cry he said I said you know and then you
want to cry I'm not going to stop you
from crying he still got the back garden
and sit down and cry and her neighbor
said she came up and she said oh you
know I thought they used to be him I
said I'm beat kids he wants to Christ on
it and cry it's his privilege yeah he
wants to cry and then she went out there
and asked him what he was crying for and
the words that came out of his mouth it
was all F this you old woman and mind
your own left in business at three years
old and it does and I've been a foster
care and I've I've studied Child
Development and what she don't realize
that all the stuff that her child needs
now growing up and debility developing
she's not giving that child she thinks
that she is but she's not because it's
more than just meeting your dad
sometimes sometimes it's like smells
Sensations you know like you know Dad's
aftershave in the house or you're dead
coming in and giving you a kiss good
night or we're sneaking down and
watching your parents you know like my
son give Mommy a kiss come on kiss her
again I saw you kiss him again you know
things like that things like that help a
child's development and she's actually a
child could be really good academically
and effed up emotionally and socially
before a child used to be shy now you
hear these children oh I'm socially
anxious what the hell and that's what
she's raising I didn't do that as well
most of these women don't even know so
like when I'm talking about the man I
grew up with the ones that got lost in
the streets and all of us like come home
oh Auntie yeah everyone good everything
and then now you're going there men's
coming out youngsta by doing whatever
you think about boys
yeah boys are different because they
might go prison and your woman your the
girls are on streets yeah well the women
the women will just yeah that's why they
say daddy issues are you mad
you got me saying British terms are you
mad crazy I've been here too long with
that bro you're funny
huh that's what you need to learn funny
funny
on the show and somebody said they
hadn't heard that in about 20 years
religion culture have a big influence in
my child right that's rubbish what I'm
saying you can't be religious if you got
divorced and that's why okay when she
said she wanted to be a traditional
woman she goes oh well you said I'm not
traditional woman I said no you're
married so you still get the chance of
going back to your husband and being
traditional once you get divorced in my
eyes you are not traditional you're just
a divorce woman marry okay I'll tell you
I'll tell you a story about someone that
actually didn't believe in divorce and
and actually was religious so this there
there's a relative that I have Catholic
okay she was a devout like you know
those people that they they just like
that is their livelihood she like I've
never seen someone so Catholic and she
had a bunch of kids and her husband was
a fireman and
um he met someone at the firehouse and
had an affair and she prayed to God I
swear she prayed to Jesus Christ for a
solution because she didn't believe in
divorce she didn't want to get divorced
he left her and so like remember this
girl broke up a marriage because he
might cheat this woman actually
religious prayed to God for a solution
the side chick died
amen I came home and she stayed with
them and she was with him for like 50
years but even if the slideship didn't
die and she'd moved in she'd never and I
don't think he would have ever divorced
her either I don't think they would have
ever got divorced because he knows her
face so much and she would have been
quite happy with that because all she
knew is that she's not breaking her vow
she I agree with her you know I think
you get married once and that should be
it yeah but it should be too difficult
and that's what I hate on my show I just
hate it when people cap like like I just
say be who you are and I respect like
honestly like there there are girls that
are complete 304s that I love I like and
because they don't cap yeah they don't
pretend to be something they're not but
it's like you're pretending to be this
like traditional religious woman when
it's like very clear you're not and you
can force some simps but you can't fool
me and I know this based on the words
you said yeah you said not not yeah okay
Faith will have a big influence my
daughter will know that she's not
bringing home a boyfriend because that's
a certain rule that I'm gonna have why
because you know but you haven't got the
rule for yourself you already said that
you're going to come and introduce your
new man eventually to your daughter so
why are you now saying that it's going
to be different she's going to cop the
children follow the parents if you go up
to be then would you expect your
daughter to be a mini sort your life out
but other girls will go to the park
don't go to the park God Is Watching do
you get what I mean what I'm teaching
now because I'm a babysitter now I was
eating outside the boys before I was
cheating everyone here let me land right
let me learn here she's gonna land she's
still gonna land we're waiting for this
plane to land I'm saying is people can
obviously how you raise your child
especially culture religion and I'm a
British mom our parents didn't have when
she Bangladeshi before
she markets herself it's like no this is
what they do it's like um they Market
them ourselves because she's trying to
be this is alleged right I know they're
going to watch this and be like oh wow
she doesn't know me I don't actually
know you and I don't actually know your
life but if I had to guess she markets
herself as like Bangladeshi and like
more traditional because that's like
appealing to men yeah but then she'll
like talk and you're like I don't think
that's as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible